Japanese folklore and mythology consists
of many legendary creatures and
supernatural beings we often refer to
them as yokai if there are supernatural
being or Carmy if there are type of
shinto god
today we'll be taking a look at a
creature that can often be regarded as
both a yokai and Carmy
the Tengu are quite popular figures in
Japanese folklore and their unique
appearance has made them quite easy to
identify for even those in the Western
world the origins of the Tengu like many
other things in Japanese and Asian
folklore is thought to have derived from
traditional Chinese literature the term
Tengu is believed to have been borrowed
from the Chinese Chango a demon canine
figure that was often thought to
resemble a comet or a shooting star
sometimes even being referred to as the
celestial dog the first of a mention of
the Tengu can be found in the 23rd
chapter of the nihon shoki written in
the year 720 the book itself is
considered to be the second oldest piece
of classical Japanese history the first
of a documented account of the Tengu was
by a Buddhist priest who claimed that it
appeared as a large shootin star in the
form of a heavenly dog
the Tengu did have a go quite a strange
and unexplained transformation as it was
rarely ever seen as a dog but rather a
large bird of prey almost raven or eagle
like and this has led many to believe
that the origins of the Tengu may have
been from the Hindu deity Garuda much
like the later depictions of the Tengu
Garuda was seen as human-like but with
the wings of a bird and a beak the
behavior of the two did differ gruder's
thought to have been much friendlier and
the Tengu are dangerous and aggressive
it's thought that when Buddhism first
arrived in Japan images of Garuda were
combined with an ancient shinto bird
demon creating the Tengu the Tengu are
quite commonly seen as large birds of
prey but over the years they're
transformed into bird-like men human
figures were the wings of birds in a
beak the beak itself slowly transformed
into an unnaturally long nose which
along with their red faces has become
their most recognizable feature a
feature that is often exaggerated an
artistic works almost resembling the
fictional character of Pinocchio the
change from a beak into an elongated No
thought to ally in associate the tengu
or solitary Co or commie the leader of
the Shinto gods on earth who was also
commonly seen over large and pointed
nose the tangley were known for their
skills in martial arts as well as their
great strength and power where the Hindu
god garuda was shown to be a friend to
buddhism but angular thought to be quite
the opposite often disrupted and playing
tricks on the buddhist priests and
samurai they considered to be arrogant
the Tang goos long noses are also
thought to represent a hatred for
arrogance and Prejudice and they
themselves are also often associated of
Buddhism it was quite common for the
priests who only cared about personal
gain to use the Buddhist teachings to
mislead other people they would then be
punished and turned into Yama bushy
Tengu this leads us to our next topic of
discussion the different types of Tengu
the Yamabushi Tengu appeared human and
it's thought that they were able to
transform into man woman or child their
preferred appearance was that of an
elderly hermit or monk like figure quite
often barefoot and with their customary
long nose the second type of Tengu is
the karasu-tengu large crow like figures
which are often more bird than man these
Tengu are not seen as tricksters but as
evil and menacing spirits they would
often kidnap children start fires and
punish anyone they see damage in the
forest at times they were known to
abduct people who were walking through
the forest these unlucky individuals
would eventually be released but they
would return in the state of dementia
known as Tengu kakushi meaning hidden by
a Tengu there have been numerous
Japanese folk tales over the years that
feature the Tengu the Tengu z' magical
cloak is a story where a boy wandering
through the forest finds a regular piece
of bamboo he placed the bamboo to his
eye and began to use it as a telescope
and nearby Tengu who had been watching
the boy was so overwhelmed by curiosity
that he jumped down from his tree and
told the boy he was willing to trade for
a magical cloak that turned the wearer
invisible having tricked the Tengu the
boy accepted the trade and continued on
his mischievous ways with his newfound
cloak
the old man's lump removed is a story
where we see the Tengu as trickster like
spirits one day an old man was wandering
through the mountains he came across a
group of Tengu dancing and drinking he
decided that he would join them and the
tangu were so impressed by his dancing
that they removed the lump from his face
assuming that he would return the next
day and asked for the lump back when one
of the old man's unsavory and unpleasant
neighbors had heard of his good fortune
he decided that he would also visit the
Tengu hoping that they would do the same
for him when he asked the Tengu they
refused givin him the first lump in
addition to his own why exactly the tank
who did this could be down to several
reasons the old man asked him for a
favor they clearly had not earned may
have angered the Tengu or maybe he's
dancin just wasn't as good as the first
man the final story that I like to cover
today is that of a gambler who meets a
Tengu the Tengu then asked the man what
he's most scared of the gambler suspect
that this may be a trick says that he is
terrified of gold when the man asks the
same question the Tengu replies
truthfully saying that he's scared for
nee plants the man then grabbed one of
the thorny plants when the Tang goes
back was turned and proceeded to mock
him waving the plant in his face in
retaliation the Tengu then summoned the
man's greatest fear rainin down gold
upon him but of course the gambler was
not scared
he had just tricked the Tengu and he was
now rich many of these folktales seem to
have similar themes behind them the
Tengu quite often attempt to trick and
outwit humans who in turn do the same
knowing that if they are successful a
great prize awaits them throughout the
years the Tengu have been through a
series of transformations and the
personality and behavior does vary
drastically from evil bird-like spirits
who were feared by most to pranks the
spirits who thrive upon targeting the
arrogant and the prideful or even
protectors of the forest it's no
surprise of so much flexibility and
variety that the Tengu have become a
staple of Japanese pop culture appearing
in countless games animes and mangas
storylines that feature any kind of
yokai will often feature a Tengu or two
to me personally the Tengu appear as a
jack-of-all-trades of Japanese creatures
and that does create an element of
surprise when reading stories about them
as you never really know what type of
Tengu you're about to see
I hope you guys enjoyed today's video if
you have any thoughts or you'd like to
share any stories about the Tengu then
please do so in the comments below as
always I've been your host with ology
and fiction explained
[Music]